today I'm going to tell you something
about circles okay so you know some
things in MTH we do because like we're
trying to solve a problem right like we
want to get a rocket ship to the moon or
whatever and some things in math we do
because we've just been doodling on a
piece of paper and wondering what's
going on so this is more in the like
paper doodling category here's the basic
question can I fill up let's say an
infinite sheet of paper with
circles the way that I've said this to
you this seems really obvious right P
like I just draw a bunch of circles I
can draw as many as I want I cover the
entire sheet of paper but if I impose
some rule like say I don't want any two
of the circles to touch each other right
to like overlap or even share a single
point in common then this is a much less
obvious question this is called a
partition by the way when we don't allow
them to touch each other the very first
thing I'm going to have to do is draw
one
Circle so once I've drawn this one
Circle then I have actually now two
questions to ask one is can I cover up
the the inside of the circle with
circles the other is can I cover up the
outside of the circle with circles now
one of those two questions is actually
pretty easy to solve if I want to cover
up the outside of the circle with
circles I can just do this so take the
same Center for all my circles and just
increase the radius of course you want
to imagine that I'm doing this for every
possible size of circle bigger than my
first one but that'll cover up the
entire outside of the first Circle that
I drew and since trying to answer this
question all always starts with a first
Circle we can always do this sort of
infinite piece of the paper is not
really any problem so the question
really then is I have this disc inside
of a circle how can I cover it up with a
bunch of circles that don't touch each
other the first thing you might want to
do is just like on the outside just
shrink your circle sizes to cover up all
of the points inside of this disc
there's a little problem with that plan
which is what happens at the end of that
game right so we have these smaller
circles but but we're never going to get
a circle that covers this center point
but you say well well well well
well I only tried this particular
covering of the disc so maybe instead
why don't I put like a circle here and a
circle there and maybe a circle like
this with different centers and
different sizes it turns out that the
answer is that you actually cannot do
this okay you are always going to miss
at least one point when you try to cover
the inside of a circle so the disc disc
with circles that don't touch each other
and the reason why is because of almost
exactly the same thing that goes wrong
with my red circles if I start trying to
cover a disc like this with circles well
let's think about this Center Point if I
can cover this disc with circles that
Center Point has to live on one of them
now the circle that it lives on whatever
it is say this big it can't be too large
right cuz if the the width of the circle
the diameter of this circle was large
enough then it would run into my first
Circle so that forces a size restriction
on the circle containing this center
point but that second Circle has its own
center point so we draw the center there
and that's got to be in some circle to
but it has to have pretty small width as
well and so when I keep looking at these
centers whatever circles they lie on the
widths are getting smaller and smaller
and smaller and so we're all shrinking
down and at the end of the process we're
going to end up with a single point here
just like in the original example that
cannot lie on any of the circles all
right so we cannot cover this plane
right this two-dimensional space with
circles why don't we add a dimension and
work with space instead once you do that
you can cover the entire
three-dimensional space with circles
it's not going to have some sort of
simplification like this where I cut it
into an infinite piece and a finite
piece because if I think about a circle
living in space right I've got
everything sort of all around my circle
I don't have two separate pieces that
the circle cut space into okay but this
is actually to our benefit so let me
show you how to do this we're moving to
three dimensions we need a whole new
piece of paper right so here's say two
dimensions and here is my magical coming
out of the
paper Third Dimension if I think about a
three a two-dimensional sphere living in
our three-dimensional space right so you
know like a globe or something just the
surface of a globe um if I remove two
points from that sphere then I get
something that I can cover with circles
so
here's my best sphere let's take away
these two points okay I'm going to
partition my sphere into circles just by
drawing circles around these missing
points again there's lots and lots of
these infinitely many of them but
hopefully you can see that they sort of
stack on top of each other to hit every
point on the sphere that's not one of my
two x's so this is the the trick that
we're going to use any sphere when we we
get rid of two points can be covered by
circles we're going to take our
threedimensional space and I'm going to
put some initial circles on there so
let's put some coordinates all right so
I'm going to draw an initial set of
circles in my three-dimensional space
but actually it's just going to be like
in those first two Dimensions I'm not
even going to think about the Direction
coming out of the paper yet so here's
one and here's another one supposed to
be a circle okay so all these sort of
WID two radius one circles with centers
on these integer coordinate points right
so I've got these circles sort of spaced
out on the flat part of my
three-dimensional space how this helps
me now is if I draw a sphere centered at
the red Point here okay then let's think
about how my red sphere that I drew hits
the black circles that I drew first the
black circles all live in this flat part
of space given you know the desktop or
the brown paper right and so the circles
on the brown paper the sphere that I
drew will only touch the circles exactly
where it hits the brown paper too right
so I want to think about slicing my
sphere off right by where the brown
paper is and look at what happened here
so how many points did I hit any of my
black circles I hit two points that was
just for the example that I drew but
actually if you sort of stare at my
construction the location of my circles
were chosen very carefully so that any
sphere that I draw that's centered at
this red point will hit exactly twice
one of the black circles and so that's
how I get my circle covering of this
three-dimensional space first I draw
this family of black circles they go on
in every direction and then I draw every
single sphere that's centered at this
red point now any of those spheres can
then be covered by Circles by themselves
and so each of those spheres can be
covered by all of these circles and
putting them all together I get a way to
cover the entire three-dimensional space
with circles then you might ask why am I
caring so much about circles a circle
after all is just like the collection of
points in a two-dimensional space which
are some fixed distance away from a
center well that's actually what a
sphere is too if I'm in
three-dimensional space instead of
two-dimensional space so maybe the right
question to ask is can I cover
three-dimensional space with spheres
that don't touch each other in fact for
almost exactly the same reason that we
couldn't do the two-dimensional space
with circles you cannot cover the
three-dimensional space with
two-dimensional spheres you're always
going to have something left no matter
what you try to do two-dimensional
spheres can be used to cover five
dimensional space but this very simple
well okay a little complicated but if
you stare at it for a little while it's
not so bad this very simple construction
for circles in R3 has not so far
provided a guide for how we might might
expand that up a dimension for spheres
in R4 right four dimensional space in
general I think the question is is not
completely known about if you take a
sphere in some number of dimensions and
you take a space of some number of
Dimensions when can you say it's
possible to partition the space into
spheres of that
Dimension what are the prime divisors of
each element of this sequence look like
that seems like a harder question well
it might be a harder question depending
on how specific you want to get but so
what I mean by the prime divisors of
elements of the sequence is we have
these factors so each number factors
into prime numbers as long as we're
ignoring zero here so three is already
Prime so this is actually a really good
point this is exactly what I want to
talk about is that if you just randomly
do this choose some number
c